well I mean I think I've in the past
five years I've really just been
inspired and kind of modeled a lot of
decisions I make off Richard Branson in
virgin you know what I love about what
Richard Branson's done you know
specifically early in his career was he
took a brand that was counterculture
sarcasm irreverent and he applied it to
all these different industries that
really weren't connected at all but he
but he gave the same customer kind of
this loyalty of this ability to be loyal
to a cell phone or an airline or a
record label and I think that is really
cool and I think it shows that it is
possible for brands to kind of kind of
transcend their specific category the
main thing with toms shoes was I wanted
to create a very comfortable lightweight
slip on that you could wear any time so
vans and converse have kind of owned
that category but the evangel converse
have a very thick kind of heavy bottom
and so Tom's is a very thin light rubber
bottom so it almost feels like a house
slipper that you can wear outside and is
really the design is inspired by the
traditional Argentine shoe called alpha
gotta and the Alpha gotta has a rope
sole which looks really cool but this
isn't very comfortable and it falls
apart when ever gets wet so by changing
it to the rubber sole now I gave it to
more comfort it's a little bit more
urban and it lasts a lot longer and so
for me Tom's is a shoe that's all about
travel it's about comforts about leisure
eh they think you can squeeze up and you
can put them in a you know in a laptop
bag and carrying with you you know on a
trip you can do there is no metal in
them so you can wear them through
airport security there's a lot of good
reasons why Thomas or perfect for
traveling but they're also perfect for
just walking in the park on a saturday
afternoon
oh yeah people call me Tom's every day
and if they don't call me Tom they want
to meet Tom and their eyes disappointed
when they meet me and they wanted the
first question is so I thought tom is
coming so the Tom stands for tomorrow
and that's really where our focus is I
mean the whole business model is based
on making a better tomorrow and and so
there is no Tom but I kind of feel like
everyone who gets behind this movement
whether it be an employee a journalist
you know a store owner they're all all
together we're kind of Tom and that's
really you know kind of our focuses on
tomorrow